yeah I like being around more than
anyone else
Angie Mac we miss you we absolutely
loved how the series ended you are going
to art school your birth parents are
married
TJ is totally into Syrus and Buffy is
back with Marty it was the perfect
ending but we wish there was more you
had so many amazing episodes that it's
hard to pick a favorite we want to know
what is your favorite moment find out
what seems the cast of Annie Mac loves
the most
keep watching to discover Peyton Lee's
two favorite moments I wonder what would
have happened if we met when we were
older panic attacks one of the best
parts of Andy Mack is all the serious
issues at dealt with Jonah started
experiencing panic attacks after his
first breakup this is a sure angels
favorite scene it was a really emotional
moment in the film he had to be very
vulnerable but he also had to make sure
he portrayed panic attacks accurately
and he did a great job he said he loves
being able to show that even the popular
kid in school has major issues to deal
with every day
Asher got a lot of positive feedback
from fans who can totally relate to
Jonah's struggles
Jonah's songs we loved watching Jonah
and Andy together through the series
Andy's crush grew into a real
relationship and they ended up friends
even after they broke up it's always
been yours I made it for you but one of
Peyton Elizabeth Lee's favorite moments
was at the beginning of their
relationship she and Jonah were getting
more and more comfortable around each
other and Jonah totally melted Andy's
heart when he sang her a song it melted
our hearts too when he's saying being
around you he revealed that he finally
understood his feelings for Andy mom and
daughter dance Bex and Celia have a
super complicated relationship they are
always at odds but through the series
they really start to understand each
other a little more
Lauren Tom who played Celia revealed
that her favorite scene was one of those
major moments in their relationship when
Becks and Celia danced together Celia
was able to reveal a side of herself
that Becks had never seen Beck's was
able to understand that her mom was a
lot more complex than just being uptight
and controlling learning disorders okay
this favorite scene actually belongs to
the executive producer instead of a cast
member but it's too important to leave
out Michele Manny and produced the show
she also directed her favorite episode
Buffy tells TJ that he might have a
learning disorder discal kulia is
basically dyslexia for numbers and it's
fairly common it was so important for a
major TV show to portray learning
disabilities in a positive light TJ just
needed some additional help
we love high IndyMac broke down the
stigma of learning disabilities the
season 2 finale the creators of Andy
Mack sure knew how to leave us hanging
at the end of a season
Trent Garrett who plays Bowie said his
favorite episode was the season 2 finale
and we can't blame him it was so intense
max and Andy had planned a huge proposal
for Bowie but then he gets offered a
dream deal he gets to reunite with his
band and go on tour the episode left us
wondering what would happen to Bowie and
Becks we are so glad that they
eventually did get married Buffy's mom
comes home Buffy's mom was in the
military and that was super hard for her
her mom was gone a lot so their
relationship was strained Sofia Wiley's
favorite scenes were the ones with her
mom and she loved the scene where her
mom comes home she pulled her emotions
from stories her dad told her about
growing up on military bases Sofia loved
that her character had a strong mom to
look up to and to learn from even if she
wasn't always around the proposal Beck's
and Andy had a lot of great moments as
they learned to honor their mom and
daughter relationship we loved all their
bonding scenes so what do these amazing
scenes was Beck's favorite Milan Bowden
revealed that her favorite moment with
Andy was when they were planning the
proposal it was the last scene they were
shooting for the season so it was really
emotional they had some real-life
bonding over hot chocolate and tears -
Buffy breaks down Sofia Wylie love's
crime scenes so one of her favorite
scenes is when she totally breaks down
in front of her mom in season 2 they
have to leave for her mom's new job but
Buffy doesn't want to leave her friends
she tried to hold all of her feelings
inside she feels like she has to be
tough for her military mom when she
finally can't hold it in anymore she and
her mom have a really sweet moment and
she learns it's okay to cry
Cyrus comes out Disney Channel made
history with this emotional scene
and it is Josh Russia's favorite moment
in the series we can't blame him because
this was such a powerful episode when
Cyrus came out to Buffy about liking
Jonah it was so emotional
Buffy figured it out and asked him Cyrus
is space when she asked if he'd liked
Joe no was heartbreaking but thankfully
he had amazing friends her real mom one
of Peyton Lee's favorite moments is
actually from the very first episode
Beck's tells her that she is her real
mom instead of her sister Peyton said it
was such a challenging scene to film
because she had never had to deal with
anything that's serious but Andy was
feeling a lot of big emotions at that
moment this scene set up the premise for
the whole show and we think Peyton and
LaLanne did an amazing job what is your
favorite moment from Andy max let us
know in the comments section thanks for
watching be sure to LIKE and subscribe
for more great content
[Music]